dream
[Music]
thank you waiting for my stream
I agree it's not the most exciting
gotta do
[Music]
let your dog
[Music]
are you waiting for my stream i think
you waiting for last year
hey I think that this is the stream
don't go anywhere cuz I'm gonna stream
hope you're watching for me and not
skill
cuz when I'm playing
I have no chill
watch my stream I gotcha
[Music]
as if I don't then they're all wrong
[Music]
10 out of 10 AV
that's me
[Music]
you guys just hang out I'm all out alert
we'll be lies
you
[Music]
it's a freak show welcome to my free
show yeah it's a free show this is also
a free show so grab some popcorn
[Music]
yeah good time everybody likes it stops
Bree shields are free fun but is you
better when it's free
yeah yeah
yeah it's a pretty show take a seat so
glad you could be here
[Music]
oh here we go about to collide
glad you're here take a seat here we go
[Music]
whoa hello everybody oh I love that song
Mary awesome Simona hey welcome to our
chill when Z play for all stream with
Mary kiss the one and only GameSpot
legend Mary Kish twitches Mary Kish my
friend Mary Kish and your friend too I'm
so happy that we get to hang out for a
couple hours today thank you so much for
joining us for play for all and hello to
the chat we are live on YouTube twitch
Mary's twitch and yeah we're just here
to chill have some fun times play a
really relaxing side scroller and hang
out with Mary we'll see my own sorry I
get distracted so easily well I have
news for you
I have alerts on which means you're
going to be distracting a lot that is
great thanks Matt so I was fun
yes Matt it's gonna be wild I do have my
alerts on so bits and subs will make an
announcement but most importantly we're
doing this for charity so every time you
guys donate to those links that we have
Jesse's gonna read them out loud so we
can thank you because you're so awesome
yes so we are still raising money for
black lives matter and Cova 19 Direct
Relief we've got those links right here
on the screen they're also in the
description if you are on GameSpot's
chat and also we'll have people dropping
that in the chat on gamespot as well but
yeah I'll be reading them out whenever
you donate and so we've got a couple of
fun things in terms of donations if you
donate $10 at least Mary's gonna write
your name on the board behind her and
then we will show that periodically
throughout the stream so your name will
be added to this and then if you donate
at least $20 Mary's gonna put a sticker
on her face and we're gonna decorate
Mary all nice
by the end of the street kind of
stickers do you got I got I don't know
how well these are gonna show up but I
have rainbow unicorns you're gonna look
great and I have these appear to be
various zoo type animals there's
definitely like lions and rhinos and
tigers oh my on here oh my you're going
right here based on you guys hopefully
you guys are able to contribute if you
are able because it's a wonderful cause
and I'm just so excited to participate
so thank you I'll tell them about the
game that you're playing right now I
don't know too much about it I just know
that this is a game called bright bird I
found it on a list of what we call cozy
games which is like a game that you're
supposed to play if you just feel like
relaxing or kind of Zen out like more of
like a easy not not easy because it's
actually a puzzle platformer so I do
think it's actually complicated but
relaxing experience so that's what I did
it's made by a Chinese indie developer
which I thought was really neat but I
have not played this before and so just
like as a preface for this
oh my mic is popping [ __ ] yeah a little
bit your mic is palpable I wonder what
could cause such a thing hmm do you want
to plug your mic in again mmm I can
unplug it and replug it back in but my
cousin yes sir
earnest but it's our settings
[Music]
okay what does it sound like now yep
sounds good okay cool I just had to
reset my audio apologies I hope that
didn't happen again I'm gonna just
double-check that I don't have anything
running that you don't need to so this
can happen all sorts of reasons one of
the major reasons it happens is when I'm
just running too much [ __ ] and my
computer is basically like we feel
overwhelmed so I can like sign out of a
bunch of stuff just to make sure that
I'm not over running it it's a bit hot
it's summer so my computer Kate overheat
just like anybody's computer and that
results in Mike Papa CH so hopefully
that fixed it makes sense so thank you
to all of us all of you who are joining
and F to everyone who's donated so far
to play for all if you've already
donated thank you so much
but if you haven't please consider
donating every dollar counts those links
are on the screen and if you're in the
GameSpot chats they are in the
description and people are dropping them
in chat as well so as I said right
before this technical difficulties every
ten dollars will write your name on the
board $20 and we'll decorate Mary's face
with stickers so shall we jump into this
game sure so yeah as I mentioned oh the
only thing you missed was like a tiny
cutscene that was basically like that
there's something going on in the world
and that we're looking for a bright bird
that's pretty much it so we didn't
really miss too much or a bright bird so
we don't know it's just a bright bird we
don't know anything about this bird no
we don't really I think this village
head is gonna explain it got it and I
also think it should be prefaced that
because this is made by a Chinese
developer you'll definitely see that in
the writing and it basically in
everything it's stunningly beautiful and
the audio is so wonderful so hopefully
you guys can like enjoy this indie
experience with me it's not like this
triple a polished game this is just a
nice light-hearted experience for
everybody so if you want to read it yeah
say that's right that's very joe and
hello to Sebastian Sebastian Ramsay in
the chat saying hi to us
hi okay here we go
the ominous haze has covered the world
every place is in chaos and everyone is
in panic they wonder what can be done
that's me I'm Yao hmm there is a
legendary bird the bright bird it can
disperse darkness and purify the world
if we can find it the haze will sure be
driven away the bright bird again the
way to find it is full of obstacles
challenges and dangers not to mention
the ominous haze my girl why do you keep
searching for such unreal things grandpa
grandpa I've heard so many amazing
legends about the bright bird they sound
so real I believe they are not only
fairy tales there gonna be a way to find
it some people in the village set out to
find the bright bird and we never heard
from them after why do you want to take
the same path they did it's a good
question grandpa I am the only one in
the village who is immune to the haze I
need to do something to help everyone
even your parents were unable to figure
it out I don't think a little girl like
you can make it I have to be sure about
you grandpa dare you I can do so I don't
want to hear a word about it again don't
tell me what I can't do don't tell me
how to live my life grandpa um I just
tested this before just to make sure it
worked and um
they don't explain this but I'm fairly
confident this is a safe stay so that if
I like die this is where I'll pop back
up got it um I also think that this is
something like the art yeah the art is
so beautiful and I love the audio behind
it there's a lotta and it's like just an
interesting game like there's like this
alligator over here like it's a very
cool ocean game and so I thought it
would be interesting to try depending on
like how we feel I have it I have a
second game that I also think is dope so
we can like try to if we both feel we'll
see how we go I guess
yeah why are you here the village had
ordered us to keep you in the village so
I dare not to be disobedient even if I
wanted to take you with me to do
business out there feel like they named
the stood pineapple II and I am in China
pe this is a suitcase I came across on
one of my business trips but I just
can't open it you can try to figure it
out when you're here okay so I think and
I can't open it either I think this is
something that I level I will come back
to or come back to it yeah make sense
the village heads demand that you stay
in the village just do as he wants
well screw everybody here no one is
getting out it's dangerous outside the
villagers are getting weaker and weaker
I have to find bright bird to dispel the
damn haze getting spicy and the right my
brother knows it's me to guard the gate
the day today he was teasing me
oh if you help me find the lost ball on
my hat the last ball in my head I will
consider letting you go through okay so
a ball yeah so I think I see it
you see it you see it is it up there
yeah except there it is nice first
puzzle done so you'll have to work with
me chesty because like even though I did
a technical test I really don't know
what is in store for us
mm-hmm so we'll find out what this game
is like if you get lost open the scroll
and you will find your way home okay so
it's my X button so this is the map it
looks like let's go
so this is me it looks like X and J tree
yeah I I was really um interested in
playing this because of the trailer
which was like super calming and super
pretty and I just thought it looked nice
I already feel relaxed cuz of this music
who are you do you get sick from the
haze - I am from the other side of the
mountain
my name is you and I'm a member of the
wings Kingdom for generations we worship
birds I heard that the Emperor's here
was once taken under the wing of the
bright Birds so I came to pay a visit I
never thought that the Empress the
bright bird oh oh I see had there is
someone being captured hang hang in
there wake up he passes out what should
we do
can we get someone to help who will help
him that dudes all passed and resting on
a rock yeah that's what they did back
then on the rocky go let go of me bring
me down bring me down you bandits hey
you don't expect me to give you given
just because you caught me
we will never really catch a
kind-hearted doctor like you if anything
I would call it a warm welcome that's
right our bosses was wounded by wicked
people that's why we are here to invite
you hmm cut the nonsense a doctor would
be devoted to his patients no matter the
cause of the disease how kind you are to
show my gratitude I decided not to rob
for the next 3 days
Wow but a knife wow what a nice guy
three days if you keep on robbing and
stealing in the haze I will tell on you
please doctor Jin can we talk about it
there's nothing to talk about leave it
aside boss is waiting
bring him down first you're right even
if we are caught we still can surrender
to the Empress and redeem ourselves by
offering our service oops I skipped are
short of hands now bring your boss here
I'm tired of shouting I need a break
what what just do as he wants he can't
go anywhere anyway all right so there's
a doctor in a tree there is a doctor
need his help to help the man sleeping
on the rock show yourself how did you
notice me I have a great vantage point
up here after all
why are you well questions aside do you
spot the rope down there hurry and bring
me down alright oops he's a little
cranky pants yeah he's in the cage I
feel like I would be cranky too yeah
nail it are you okay I'm fine just a
little thirsty from the shouting what's
your name my name is Yao Jun just now I
heard them talk about the Empress do you
know anything about the bright bird in
fact I once got enlightened but from the
power of the bright bird that's why I
could wait that's why I acquired ability
to heal people oh then you can save my
grandpa and other villagers in the
nearby village and the man passing out I
saw on the way there's a dude pass out
on a rock that I left back there they're
gonna help him out a bead oh by the way
you mentioned the power of the bright
bird have you seen the bird before no I
just know a thing or two about the power
but I will go and save those villagers
now let's leave this place as it's not
safe to talk here I accidentally came
here and I'm sure my way back will be
even more dangerous if possible could
you please help do a safety check ahead
sure send the girl for her theater it's
a lot of dialogue but I
get setting up the story here I don't
know what these are is that it could be
some kind life's urgency some kind of
delicious mint currency alright cool so
we are progressing here and I'm learning
some options that I have right like I
can jump and I can climb and these are
some kind of bouncy mushroom bouncy
mushrooms
I'm in love with her like bouncing
animation which is just her spinning
around I like the sound effect a lot fun
nice to meet you
why are you sneaking around you look so
fishy I say this a lot mm-hmm
my toes name is one some how we seem to
share a destined bond can we be friends
friends what friends nevermind
it's dangerous ahead why are you going
there I'm leaving for the brightburg or
looking for the bright fruit you don't
know what you're talking about how about
taking me with you at least I can be
muscle [ __ ] you am I supposed to cover
your meals a port then forget it
oh don't be hasty
alright I'll take care of it myself ok
ok great
so I've acquired a dude and I can switch
to him oh and I think that each have
different skills nice so he appears to
be muscle so maybe I can muscle this
tree branch down yeah wow so strong um
he made that look easy
he does make it look easy
nice nice but those of you just joining
we are raising money for black lives
matter and Cova 19 Direct Relief the
links are on the screen or if you're in
GameSpot chat then they are in the
description or in the chat so please
donate and for every ten dollars we're
gonna put your name on the board and
every twenty dollars Mary's gonna
decorate her face with stickers sticker
did you see this is what turtle crazy
turtle Wow I like it we're getting
places now
okay so I'm fairly confident this is
death that's what I would have tried um
okay so this is our first environment
puzzle here yeah we can't use the vines
I think I can write like I think that
the circles to me are trying to tell me
that I can but I can't reach them okay
and there's this fellow got some
donations oh cool I read I'm gonna read
a couple donations here and we've got
someone for the board so I'm gonna give
you their names so they can get written
on the board amazing you can send that
sympathy score - so Matt Hawking $10 hi
chastity and Mary looking forward to the
stream thank you so much Matt you were
going on the board you're the first one
on the board thank you so much and I
want to shout out to one of the
donations that came in yesterday that
didn't get read from Kevin Warner who at
the very end of the what's good game
stream gave $25 to black lives matter
and $25 $20 to direct relief so thank
you for donating to both causes thank
you so much that really means a lot to
us and that was Ken oh you should go uh
yeah Kevin Kevin I'll write his name for
you Kevin Warner is on the board thank
you so much for that and then we oh we
have another donation from Hassoun cuz
soon thank you so much because soon I
see you in the chat often twenty one
dollars and 21 cents and it says paper
Mary sticker stars and women stickers
for her soon for donating twenty one
dollars thank you so much on the board
this will go maybe here for now I'm
gonna assumes in the twitch chat so a
sticker a yeah let's get some sticker
action and correction C had rainbows and
your danimals right yeah does the
student want anything in particular or
socially clothes or animals as soon
they're both very curious you Eric you
thank you so much for your donation if
you would like to donate the links are
on the screen and I will be reading them
out
thanks to this ho ho ho soon also gets
his name on the board too soon yeah he's
on there sweet love it
rainbows Hassoun would like rainbows you
got it you got it okay it's going right
on the forehead love it okay cool
this'll be good all right got a we've
got several more donations go for that
lives matter thank you so much all right
so before we get back to the game nawaz
kickball who is a frequent donator thank
you so much you were going on the board
$10 to black lives matter Wow huge
donation from Chris van Gorp $50 Chris
van Gorp thank you so much if you are in
the chat with me please let me know if
you would like rainbows or animal
stickers Chris thank you so much yeah
and then we've got two more we've got
Brian good row it's $25 so Brian if
you're in the chat please let me know
what sticker you would like thank you
Brian
for $25 to black lives matter and then
Austin Freeman $10 you're going on the
board $10 to black lives matter thank
you so much Austin Freeman so thank you
guys so much you're good all going on
the board we're getting stickers over
here it's gonna be a fun time but yeah
thanks for joining us for our tools team
helping us raise money those donation
links are in the description if you're
on GameSpot right now or if you're in
Mary's chat there on the screen right
there
ly / GS - BLM but Don ly is / GS - CO
vid
excited about it already thank you all
when we're done I'm gonna decorate it
with stickers but thank you I love it
all you're nice I love it
let me check good stickers so for black
lives matter we have one to two more
stickers cool they're going on yeah I'm
gonna do if I don't hear what it is I'm
just gonna pick one I just go for it I
didn't see anything
[Music]
okay doesn't want to stick we're gonna
do a cow
that sounds love it and I think this is
a toucan hello to everyone the chat hi
everyone thank you for joining us
there's certain to this starting to
appear they look good yep all right cool
so back to the game just as a reminder
there was like a little bit of an
environmental puzzle and it looks like I
kind of sussed that out here excuse me
what are you doing here waiting
you are not the one I'm waiting for
don't stay rude okay so this is maybe
something for later
okay so I think that uh yeah what I
wasn't able to yeah what I'm seeing here
is that I need to like switch between
the two people because he is drunk and
can break branches and she is a jumper
and can like climb things so I'm kind of
going in between these two people okay I
can reach this okay this is a boulder
which means that's this guy
see no angel thanks thank you guys for
the support how's your streams been
going it's been fun it's been a lot of
fun with a lot of different friends of
GameSpot and yeah just kind of sometimes
it's an excuse for us to hang out which
is nice and raising money so that's it's
been great it's been it's been a really
good time yeah we had a really chill
podcast yesterday with what's good games
kind of fun he was playing some war zone
the other day Naomi was on we had a fun
time playing some rocket League she and
Rob were teaming up for that I saw that
we ended up I end up singing some songs
towards the end of it it was fun Rob was
singing some Spice Girls we still have
to break that out and he had a very deep
cut for his favorite Spice Girls song so
we ain't one
how would keep playing Spice Girls did
you guys like put it on YouTube and he
just no we were so no we were just
singing it no we we just brought it up
in conversation started singing acapella
amazing he thanked who became one that
was his favorite spice real song
apparently yeah I was kind of going
through some of this dial iqt yeah hmm
there is some too bad you're not a
member of my place the fandom
the female kingdom and only females are
allowed in the female Kingdom that's
right a kingdom only houses females oh
yeah this is my people would Wow
Catholic with anyone they meet and fall
in love with and if they have babies
they would keep the girls and send away
the boys that's their system
oh yeah I was having the talk oh no run
they're gonna they're gonna copulate
you mean you're here to hunt for a
husband actually no I heard in the North
there is a nation run by females I was
off to have a look unfortunately my way
was blocked by the Hayes just as I was
about to go back i came across jin a
charming guy if i don't come with him
and pass down is pretty news to our
future daughters and ultimately to my
nation
so i am beholden to can you help
persuade jin i don't know exactly what
happens here but to get our passage i
think you might as well go with her
please don't make fun of me any longer
brother i am up to something serious and
urgent can't afford to lose any time but
now you can't go anywhere anyway but
could you please brave the haze ahead
with yow and bring Shang and gong to
help me fine for yow sake I'll do you
the favor if it was Yoshi would have
done the same anyway okay stay here and
wait hmm no one can help him all right
we're getting there
oh we go oh oh oh' coulis in the box I
think it was money or whatever the
currency of this game is yeah she's good
I think that Mary you have a shout out
in the YouTube chat from LOI she said
you are my fav streamer please say hi to
Chloe hi Chloe
thanks for yeah yeah you know with us
yeah we even talked about that too much
but if you guys aren't familiar I used
to work at GameSpot and I love GameSpot
very much and I work at twitch now and
I'm actually head of community marketing
at twitch so that is awesome I'm also
streaming this on my twitch channel and
GameSpot's channel so we're all over the
place today having a fun time
chillin on a Wednesday raising money for
black lives matter and Co V 19 jerk
relief chillin on oh we have those links
in the description and in the chat I'll
be dropping those links in to the chat
too okay so to me this is another puzzle
where I can't jump any higher so I need
to be able to get up there so I'm gonna
switch to strongman strong and we're
gonna move this thing
it's interesting it looks like it should
hold it here but I'm gonna try and get
up here first let me stand on that no I
can I can he is able to get up here and
everything
this requires three and I only have that
essentially this is something I come
back to later as well
can you stand on that yeah oh okay it is
a button that makes this frog birth
water it does it go into there I think
it does okay yeah yeah there yeah so
okay
Oh see this bird it's got a little seed
in his mouth oh he does so I'm gonna
scare him pretty yes hey Bart ha nice
yeah
killing it wow that planted fast look
how quickly that plant grew yeah I
started gardening for the first time
this year I don't know anything about
gardening me neither my magical in this
game this is a flower but I can't touch
it uh-huh can one of the other
characters interact with it right that's
a good idea
all right she's scratching her head so
it's not her maybe like someone needs to
talk about it yeah maybe we missed
something you have a question from the
YouTube chat Mary are you excited for
the new resident evil it's from Chris
yes I'm so excited um Mike and I've
already been talking about it a lot and
we're really looking forward to playing
another game in the Resident Evil series
you guys a lot of gamespot people
remember we played through all of them
one one through seven in a row
and then we even included some of the
ones that aren't in the numbered series
like code Veronica and we owe sunlight
sunlight sunlight sunlight sunlight
sunlight sunlight so that makes sense
and I've turned it into that mushroom
that's bouncy so I'm gonna turn into the
girl so that I can bounce on it and keep
going so yeah the plan is to play it
once it comes out we're currently
playing through dead space because we've
played through the scary the Resident
Evil games
nice so we'll continue to do that well
we do that currently on my twitch
channel and it also actually goes on my
YouTube channel on YouTube in case we
you know you miss it nice alright
there's so much dialogue I'm gonna go
through a little bit of it go for it
thank you to Wendy Hernandez for five
dollars Direct Relief thank you so much
Wendy bird scene CD Oh wizard puns going
on over here
[Laughter]
look at this cuckoo clock in the
background this game is very oh it's
great I love that art yeah these
illustrations are really good it's part
of why I picked this game is because it
has just a really it's very calming
music yeah
very enjoyable to play so relax I'm just
gonna like lay back yeah you know what
you've had a you've had a hard day
chasidy there's a cute back and enjoy
your he of thank you I'm just gonna
relax grab my plushie and go to sleep I
had all these like ideas for this stream
and a part of me was like I'm gonna like
I'm gonna like do just dance and I'm
gonna like have all this stuff going on
and then like all this stuff happened in
our industry and in the world right like
from Kovac and the black lives matter
movement and then like our industry had
a movement and there was all these
things that were happening that were
really intense and I was like you know
what I'm gonna play something that like
I just mentally like that's what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna play something that I
enjoy and that will be that and we'll
have fun and that will be enough for me
cuz I like hanging out with chastity I
don't need fancy things I just need your
company I just need just need a buddy
yeah all right Chloe asks Mary do you
like this game yeah I like it so far
it's um it's a very calming experience
which is nice I do think that the
puzzles are not intuitive for me I'm
like finding myself
struggling a little bit but that's okay
as long as you guys don't like get
annoyed with how much I am struggling
but like I don't mind struggling through
a puzzle game it doesn't bother me yeah
rough on the edges but that's yeah yeah
that's part of the fun that was figuring
it out and then it feels so rewarding
when you do figure it out yeah I mean
I'm a huge advocate of indie games I
think that they come in all shapes and
sizes
you know a lot of the indie games that
we oh [ __ ] I don't even have that many
32 Jade beads
I don't even answer that they're called
are you mocking me don't waste anything
you don't have money all right so I need
to get 32 and then talk to me too
you have 19 so that's where we're on our
way okay so that kills me okay I've got
it there might even be yeah like some
Metroidvania elements in this where
we're gonna backtrack yeah Nintendo D
said um I got him hooked on holo night
in katana zero I play a lot of indie
games on my channel I love that and I'm
oh I'm super open to like playing those
so if you guys like those types of games
or if you just like experiencing
different games this chant like this is
a good place for you and we kind of just
test them out together and see what we
like and what we don't
it's just a big old test so I I like
knocked a huge hammer through there this
is definitely a puzzle I don't know
exactly what's going on here yeah I'm
not quite sure either
um but yeah it's fun to just try
different things they're not all winners
but that's like not the point like the
point is just to try [ __ ] and see what
you feel true what you get excited about
before we get too far into this puzzle
we've got a couple more to add to the
board dope okay I can move this rock
oh my god I'm stuck yeah what do you got
for me all right
our very own Julio pack gave us $25 get
my sticker we love the name and a
sticker oh yeah um so Lada let's add a
rainbow for Julio you got it and then
shout out to Matt Hawking $20 you're
also getting a sticker and Herman huff
$10 you're getting on the board
Matt Hawking $20 and Herman huff thank
you all for your donations take this bad
boy off so that means we got two more
stickers and if you want to be cool like
them please donate to those links you
see on screen right there donate to
black lives matter at bit.ly/msubizlib
that's like I okay I want you to know
that you're okay I'm gonna stay where is
this guy put this one here I'm gonna
caffeinate it so that I can stay awake
and I'm gonna put a rhino oops on my
forehead no all right
we have a lot of stickers going on here
cool um still sussing out this puzzle I
have no idea what's going on in it yeah
this is a tough one
but I I knocked down that probably
killed me oh okay did uh uh rip
try try again try try again this guy
needs money I don't have any so we
knocked down I have no idea what some of
this stuff is yet we're just kind of
sussing it out still um
[Music]
it keeps asking for more money yeah I
think those are the things I come back
to so I don't know if and how those are
connected but I do think like this guy
this seems oh okay something that's
happening okay okay okay make sense so
we all kind of like we're sussing out
these puzzles one by one here but a lot
of them I've never played this before so
I have no idea oh god this is death oh
that's scary
okay there's this water fountain here
can I collect the money I oh I do we
need that money at we need 32 we need ma
I need money baby he need money
who made this device it's covered in
saws why would you do this there's
nothing Zen about this section I'll tell
you that right now somebody put a bunch
of saws in here hello sir your soul is
back leaving where you belong to you
where could the world be parting from
the people you love does not bode well
okay wizard listen wizard I got my own
things what do you mean yeah yes you
said it find me what what do you mean
okay damn wizard ha you little curious
girl well I am asking how come you leave
your peaceful habitation to go on a
journey that's full of sinister risks
tut-tut I will shut up
how do you know no my name is wizard
yeah I know I don't know I'm going to
look for the bright bird and I invite
the Honorable woo to come with me
I know you will ask although I also wish
to go with you I have to test you first
wizard I will accept your listen
carefully how many people left in your
village oh [ __ ] oh does the alligator
kiss on the screen yeah probably not so
there wasn't a heaven like my fine my
grandpa there was my grandpa there was
the person who yelled at me yeah there
was another person who yelled at me and
then there was the guy with the ball in
his head size 4 but yes did I miss was
there anyone in the background there
might have been like one dude in the
background I don't know I want to save
lives like I you trust yeah I'm a wizard
now you're a wizard Harriet
oh I can't turn into him okay Oh David I
thought it was the point of that I
thought now we had like sick magic
powers and stuff wait do I have to pick
a different button to turn into him it
should be the same button right who
snoring is it a monster sit here I'll go
have a look come here yeah no monsters
but a human being who's there waking me
up Oh somebody sup to me and proud of
you
oh you are the girl who saves me in the
middle of the night I scream at six to
nine which is totally a night for anyone
who's not on my time zone thanks for
hanging out we meet again you my name is
you are yeah right I know Jen told me
thanks for asking him to save me then
why are you here
your snores sound like you are in good
health how dare you
I do feel much better now but I didn't
expect Jen would heal me with his own
blood I blood blood can heal people I
don't know why his blood can cured the
disease maybe it's because Jin is not
ordinary he mentioned the dragon statue
here was enchanted by the bright power
of luck or by luck who doesn't like luck
so it is less polluted that's why he
suggested me to recover here I
environment here is indeed a little
better but I don't think it's enough to
help you recover I think this game is
has connotations to the environment
issues and I know because the small
environment Jin told me that there's a
mechanism in the statue yeah you might
be right
we need to trigger it to bring in the
sunlight and activate the power of the
bright bird I've tried for a long time
but nothing happened
did Joe hit you any hint no hints no and
I'm also curious yeah kind hearted
doctor as he is I'm sure he was just too
busy to tell us he healed me and the
villagers nearby you know nearby grandpa
and the villagers they're fine now what
a great relief Jin was influenced by the
power before I think that's why he knows
it better let's crack the mechanism and
help you recover
I'm sure Jin has a good reason to do so
why you keep calling his name and not
mine he's so fishy definitely not a
great guy Lucas on the real fight I'm
let's deal with this badass first Wow
alright so the flood dragon wanders
around around the mountain finding the
way back to have it away back to heaven
by following the Sun this is it this is
a puzzle hmm the flood dragon with the
mountain wanders around the mountain
finding the way back to heaven by
following the Sun okay it has to do with
this for sure yes
okay here we go Oh are we connecting
them okay yes
that looks right does that look right to
you I think so try the second one one
more time oh wait no no that looks right
yeah yeah like there it is yeah you made
it I'm [ __ ] a genius you're so smart
I know there's so much dialogue
respectfully I will assume what they met
Wow look at this badass it was he big
this big Chalker yeah look at that big
old sword you offenders how dare you
destroy the bridge pay off the damage or
leave one person to repair otherwise no
one can leave okay so I either have to
hand over a teammate or pay 27 jade
beans which I don't have but I'd really
rather not hand over a teammate yeah
that's that's a big risk I'm gonna
reconsider and think about this I don't
even know how to give them a teammate I
think it would probably give you the
option if you chose it
I'm gonna give them the wizard cuz I
don't know his value yet but he might
have powers a question from the YouTube
chat I Miss Mary where she nowadays
she's over at twitched Mary do you want
to shout out that your twitch channel
sure I stream typically three times a
week on twitch.tv slash Mary Kish but my
name is spelled M ER r YK is H so as you
see it on the screen under her beautiful
face Oh someone just followed so thanks
I stream there I stream a lot of indie
games as you can see and I stream horror
games I stream
I'm currently streaming through the
entire Silent Hill series with my friend
hentai PhD and we're on Silent Hill
Homecoming which i think is considered
the fifth own in ten daddy thanks nice
we got a couple donations yes that just
came in gonna shot these out thank you
so much to donating for co v 19 direct
relief to silver strat who gave $10 a
good Wednesday with good games for good
causes thank you all and wizard of the
West
yeah $1 thank you so much that is
amazing on the board yeah alright tell
me their names that I get them right I
got this one and Wizard of West Silver
thank you thank you so much silver and
wizard and $5 just came in from
anonymous big fan of Resident Knievel
wish harima Hardy could still play
through horror games you they do just go
to Mary's channel we do weekly nature we
play once a week right now mm-hmm thank
you so much for your donation and so
those were for Coppa 19 Direct Relief
and the link is on the screen if you'd
like to donate there we also have a link
to donate to black lives matter as well
right there on the screen
silver Stratton also donated $10
they're dope that was very nice
wizard I know you're in my chat what
sticker do you want do you want um
rainbows or do you want animals from the
zoo much as a bribe to get you to do
slightly earlier stream it's hard to do
a stream because I work full time they
also work your towns rainbow wizard said
okay
[Music]
rainbow you're getting a rainbow on the
nose yep nice yeah where I I work on the
community marketing team my job is to
essentially um oh fudge fudged that up
my job is to you make community stuff
that hopefully people who either watch
twitch or stream on Twitch would like
and that could be so many different
things like I work on all of our unity
months that includes like Women's
History Month or Black History Month or
pride which is currently happening
actually still I work on those which is
really fun and then I also work on stuff
like twitchcon which is not happening
because of co vid which is unfortunate
but that's just the way it is and other
events so that's kind of what I do huh
that's awesome yeah it's kind of a weird
year though isn't it right like yes no
cons yeah mm-hmm something weird
happened yeah
okay is this like a boss fight or um and
if you've ever played through a commie
but they have the same hair character
dialogue noise which is like when you
listen to someone in Okami it's like
well I don't know if that's not a
meeting and that's kind of like what
people sound like oh oh strap stratten
thank you yes thank you thank you so
much everyone who's donated sofar see
you black lives matter and Cova 19
Direct Relief those links are on the
screen they're in the chat if you're in
GameSpot or in the description as well
cool I'm excited to decorate this poster
today yeah all right what do you guys
want no entry no entry for unrelated
personnel don't be rude this way you
okay I'm gonna be honest hustle I'm
gonna be honest with you I definitely
rushed through this so I have no idea
what this is this is a puzzle for sure
[Music]
can you come in cuz you're a boy no
entry okay so I hear you that it's a
puzzle but I have no idea what I'm doing
[Music]
I'll just leave
yeah the options are animals and
rainbows Nintendo D
I have legs ooh animals and then I have
like rainbow unicorns and rainbows whoa
this is like oh whoa that was trippy
this is like some kind of like smoke and
mirrors plays
it's a machine the culprit of haze
problem yeah this is a hundred percent a
commentary commentary right yeah alright
so they're gonna maybe work on
destroying it together
oh well that was easy take that
capitalism ya down
are you okay I just got choked by the
smoke of the machine it's not a big deal
let's go let's find a place to take
cover are you worrying about me I'm okay
I just need some rest so I stopped the
smog machine but I don't know what that
did no regrets but like why do we do the
things that we do chastity who could
possibly know
are these all portals or they just
portals I connect that side to the side
we were just at they're all portals hmm
I don't know
where they all go yet
oh my gosh there's so much dialogue in
this game yeah there is
all right much of the game can we turn
off the game I can I can that's an easy
thing the game is so beautifully
sounding too so it's a mistake not to
make sure you guys can hear it and it's
never too loud in my opinion yeah I
agree
all right cool it's kind of kind of
going through here question from the
chat you just like streaming Mary I do
like streaming it's sweet sweet thanks
for the follow I enjoy especially right
now I think there is an issue with like
you know like we're having a hard time
socializing I feel alone a lot I can't
go places and so to me streaming is my
ability to socialize it's my ability to
have some connection with the outside
world it keeps me active it keeps me
feeling like I am contributing to like
society that I have friends and then I
enjoy myself I think honestly currently
streaming is saving me like it gives me
something to feel good about in my day
to day or that so it's definitely
something that I've enjoyed oops
now more than ever before but it's also
it can be time-consuming and it can be
also physically exhausting just like
anything you have to like takes a lot of
energy to stream and so it's like make
sure I don't overdo it
oh my god look at this guy what is this
guy doing hmm this guy's a story yeah
what's what's let's talk about let's
talk about this cat right what is he'll
like it yeah what are you thinking
chewing his cud um he's just saying he's
just yelling at me oh my god this
the art eveness is really beautiful
yeah and put it back I like appreciate
the tls you'll see through the haze feel
it feel the singing birds and the
fragrance of flowers when I was still
young probably heard larks singing but
not anymore after the ominous haze be
fill you will as long as you can find
the way to dispel the haze larks will
come back you know me no you're not it
doesn't really matter I've been to
millions of places to recapture the view
in my heart all right mm-hmm
I just say you don't know me I'm running
out of jade beads
why does everyone dude I have no [ __ ]
money we still needed 32 for like way
back there was no I'll come back like
geez for an exam everything costs an
exorbitant amount of yeah I do not turn
away too much yeah Dovahkiin said the
moose deer is pretty cool yeah I was
really into that moose deer okay I've
killed myself sorry
that is like fire or something
we got some more donations all right
thank you guys for doing thank you thank
you thank you
all right to direct relief we got $10
you're going on the board from Lois
treble ryan revelry in ooo 6 just
stopped by to say her name
Thank You Lois thanks ok I will write
that in the chat for you and then over
on to black lives matter we've got a
couple donations one from David Trang
who's already donated before thank you
for being so generous to us thank you so
much for helping us raise money to these
great causes $10 you're going on the
board and Derek Houser is getting a
sticker or $25 Houser thank you
thank you thank you all you guys are so
cool thank you for doing this yeah you
guys are the best
Derek Hauser and Derek gets a sticker
bass is making noises cool I'm just
gonna pick this funky horse he just
looks like he's having a good time go
right here all right cover it here
here we go love it right back to the
game yeah it's it's a very beautiful
game it's definitely I think it takes a
lot of patience and kind of like
probably like a chill mindset to play
this so thanks for letting me kind of
like pick something that I would say is
not typical or standard it's definitely
a different type of game I have no idea
what I'm doing I'm lost again this is Oh
nice move I'm just basically using my
interact button to see what it is I can
interact with
what does that do what did that do I
have no what does this do okay so this
turns on water
[Applause]
what it does nobody knows like what's
the point
[Music]
maybe I meant to switch people and jump
up on that cliff up there I don't know
[Music]
if that makes that go up how do we get
on it that's the current yeah get up
there girl like I feel like it's not
enough time
sweet sweet Phoenix said really cool art
style agreed yeah I love the art in this
yeah we can all agree stunningly that's
why I picked it
I thought it looked really pretty and
sounded really nice
but I don't
Oh what did I just do I just kill myself
on accident who knows who's to say okay
dude sorry Oh oh yeah see moans around
we can always see at the next donation
let's see maan will come out Mary's dog
when we get the next at least $20
donation I'm too stupid to play this
game I don't know what this game is
asking of me currently we know that we
can we know that we can you turn on the
water
mm-hmm let me go higher but like yeah if
we can get the water
I don't even know what this button does
or just that thing sits on it
I'm gonna I'm gonna try and push that
button now that this has water on it and
see it better
oh yeah this makes it move different
levels interesting but but why so it's
got three different levels oh that got
rid of this button Oh likes remember how
that button was fire before no right oh
yeah
yes oh there's so I clicked it but I
don't know what if that does still damn
you
[Music]
don't consent to revert the water
perhaps oh okay yeah I can do that
dang we're so smart
I'm giving nothing happen I'm giving us
a success video because we figured that
out
[Music]
well with the quickness and I'm glad you
were there to witness sometimes I can
tell my time but you'll never say that
it's a lack of trying
we don't always get it done but when we
do I think we have a bit more fun
[Music]
thanks for blessing us with SEMA if I
have multiple win videos and one fail
video so which ones we get we get today
we got a question for you from Daniel
can Mary share some of her best memories
from working with GameSpot oh my god I
have so many you guys I had a lot of
wonderful times at gamespy definitely
like some highlights were the first time
I ever went to Japan with Peter Brown
for Tokyo Game Show that was a
tremendous experience and I'll like
always treasure like kind of having that
experience also edy from gamespot
Australia and we just had a really
wonderful time and just kind of like we
were all really happy to be around each
other it was just like one of those like
really special moments there was like
the time when rocket league was super
hot and Rob and a bunch of us we all
like made this rocket league video with
Jake Decker oh yeah that was a great
video yeah and we like made this video
so smart so that's my s MIT we made this
video about playing rocket league and
Jake died in the video it's very funny
and we had such a good time I have
multiple good rocket League video
memories I also went to rocket I went to
the headquarters like then met the
developers of rocket league to get a
first look at their map and I was like
the first person to see it and play it
which was really neat I got to see a lot
of cool people I got to meet a lot of
good people I met Mike Marty we played
Dark Souls was it Dark Souls 3 together
and we got to play the first boss
together and we went to like a winery
and ate meat without silverware because
they were like that's how we're doing it
here it was very odd and we had a guy we
had a lot of good memories I had a good
memories I'm a I've made I've made so
many good friends at GameSpot I'm still
really good friends with chassis and
Callie and Eric hey oh my god playing
until dawn until dawn oh that was a good
sort of guys have opened up you've
really opened it up this time cuz like
now we're gonna start talking about it
all it's really amazing stuff this is a
sweet puzzle dope this is why we skip
some of the dialogue yes I want to get
to this scholar can I fall how what's my
fall damage none great nothing I wonder
if I should hit all of these are just
some of these like should I hit lick
dress yeah okay yeah puts them away Oh
put them away
so you don't want to hit all of them
this is really pretty
hello it's everyone who's just joining
the chat thanks for joining us today
we're hanging out with Mary and she's
playing bright bird right now which is
this beautiful game is the side scroller
full of puzzles and we're raising money
for black lives matter and for Cova 19
Direct Relief the links are on the
screen and if you're in the GameSpot
chat there in the description as well if
I'm good thank you for asking talk soon
get that Oh who's this looks like a game
of Go up there oh my gosh do you play go
nope
I've played it like I'm so bad in it we
did um so you'd be amazed chess and go
are very popular on Twitch and people
play all the time competitively and
there's even tournaments and so I helped
introduce a go tournament with where
chat played against a professional go
play that's really cool yeah that's a
great idea
[Music]
okay so I think I have to play Oh Lord
oh Lord
what oh my gosh I didn't realize that my
life was in danger when we made this
arrangement take it easy
God quickly this supposed to be a Zen
game of five it was until this point so
you passed the test you didn't die
what's your request I want you to find
the bright bird with me okay
of course we should go now
Pik Wow have you tried to kill you yeah
yeah got him though you know and we're
back I can't believe they put sharpened
stick holes in this game I have to say I
find this whole thing a little stressful
it's starting to go
those are sometimes Oh God I'm dying a
lot right now
oh we got a name for the bore and Luis
Vasquez all right good [ __ ] I've dying
so much or Louie Luis Luis you're going
on the board
you're on the board Luis thank you for
$10 towards black lives matter thank you
so much for your donation you are on the
board appreciated all right I have to be
a little bit more cunning on this let's
do this there will be no death
[Music]
score yeah we
I am pushing down on the d-pad lookee
what happening someone else I can only
be these two people that I'm aware of
what do you want from me game oh you'll
meet alike
there we go ha ha ha ha
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's gonna take all of our cunning they
are so cunning
I know I just said that is so cool what
happened where's Jim we promised you we
would take her to the palace to visit
the Empress
so many things happening
captured
[Music]
here to solve it strap alright let's
solve this trap solve the trap it's a
trap it's a trap okay so they did say be
careful with the black smoke and there
they weren't wrong it kills you
there's something I can do here
[Music]
[Music]
okay so only when you're on
but can I just destroy this machine
somehow
[Music]
like we did with the other machine yeah
it does leak does that hurt you this
smokes does kill me okay smoke em if you
gottem yes
Sara Dib is a a double-jump
No
this button is obviously a valium down
buy something yeah but we can't get up
there and then like I don't think the
goal is to just stand on it forever
maybe it is but
let me see if there's anything we missed
down here yeah there might be something
like I feel like this is telling me
something I just don't know what it's
telling me oh my god Oh
there we go
[Music]
haha and it connects to you so there it
is there it is now what does it do what
does it mean can I like
I mean who's to say I feel like there's
a connection here there is a connection
to this like you could see that yeah you
see that line in the ground above you
it's connecting to something
totally
[Music]
so
yeah tell me what Oh
okay so that was ow is he okay I just
killed him
it's he dead is he dead did he sacrifice
himself I think he did oh that sucks
I got another donation good okay good
thank you for your donation you were
going on the board tony fong $15
no matter thank you Tony so the donation
links are on the screen right below our
game play donate to black lives matter
at bit.ly/msubizlib boo boo boo it's for
a good cause
yes thank you we be out here helping it
up out here we've got another 40 minutes
left in the stream so we're hanging out
for a little while see if it still got
time to get those donations in I'm just
kind of
through the motions here first I was
asking me what's my favorite game and
movie that's a loaded question that's
one I guess if I had to pick favorite
game of all time I would say Street
Fighter 2 it's a game I've always come
back to repeatedly my entire life and
one of the first games I really got into
a favorite movie I'm gonna go with
Empire Strikes Back I guess as if I had
to pick one movie but I'm also known at
GameSpot for being a huge fan of the
movie the faculty from to the Faculty's
so good it's thank you good it's fun to
go back to you also because most of the
cast got way more famous after that film
right and yeah like Jon Stewart's in it
as a teacher Salma Hayek's in there as a
teacher it got the t1000 in there is the
terrifying football coach I love that
movie you and I have a lot in common one
of my favorite movies is also kind of
like a like a thriller or like a scary
movie that had like people who were
lesser-known and they got more famous
might one of my favorite music slither I
really love iliyan and Elizabeth Banks
like that's right movie that's right
it's very late it's really good and it's
still really good like I watch it that's
a James Gunn movie yeah I just watched
it this past year and it still holds up
like it's still very funny yes it's
gross - it is so gross but it contains
all the aliens zombies like weird gross
gooey things that are like attacking you
like it's it's got it all it's very good
slow there's a great one
good call okay so my dude kind of like
is fine now which is interesting okay
he's alive he like woke up and was like
I lives I'm fine
I'm gonna stick my sword in here
[Music]
[Laughter]
okaythat's
apologies to everyone's ears
[Laughter]
looks like I [ __ ] up that game again
here comes that shame again
why am I so bad it makes me so sad to
Sagat gain
yes
we did it C Mon C Mon reimbursed by
Seema heard there were stickers hi C Mon
hi C mode cutie pie I miss you he's good
he's doing really well he's thriving in
Portland
I do think healing he misses II miss you
see mom I I miss I miss petting you he's
a good boy so good as long as he's
getting pets he'll be satisfied for a
little bit I wish I could pet C Mon
right now he wishes you could pet into
all he wants a spot scratches quite
honestly and truly this is great this is
his jam
[Music]
all right I guess I'll do the same thing
yep all right yeah the bulge out for the
giant boulder run do you think I'm safe
up here Oh Oh it turns no no no my way C
Mon help C Mon C Mon help dig it's that
big oh my god it's so close it's getting
so close again so close no okay okay we
learned to live close though we learned
a lot so I saw where the end point was
it falls into that hole yes I guess I
was supposed to jump I feel silly cuz it
was like it was either jump or fall in
the hole and for everything and I
thought whole book it I'm running C Mon
oh right I'm gonna die I made a mistake
this is where you want to be you can be
here I I never tell my son what to do
which leads to good and bad results
yeah
he's burping can you hear that is he
burping no I can't hear middle he's a
gassy boy I remember alright so we're
gonna run C Mon your yeah we're gonna
book it go dude book it
oh my gosh alright so we need to be
really fast with us okay I feel like
that went well am I supposed to do
my so much oh my gosh ha is there a spot
that you can like hire to run backward
it's like Hill and Simone's laying down
on my lap now so he's not really visible
[Music]
he's just doing his own thing now so I
feel like I have to jump yeah on some
stuff here we go
like I don't know what I did wrong I'm
just gonna like I don't see any openings
yeah oh my god I'm gonna die again what
am I doing wrong do you think I should
stop which to the girl I don't know cuz
that takes time to see yeah see if she's
any faster
wait but she can't open the hill no so
I'd have to I'll open the hill switch to
her and then run switch to her yeah I
didn't work try that yet right I think
she's a little oc1 didn't like that no
looks about the same
I'm obviously just doing it wrong I just
don't know what it is I'm doing wrong
yeah just one second we got 20 more
dollars from silver strat and thank you
so much
they said one more time for the day
thank you so much silver you're already
on the board but you get another sticker
I'm gonna definitely do another sticker
we're gonna do lime
I appreciate the donation the donation
links are on the screen right there just
filled down ly / GS - balaam bitte ly /
GS - of it
alright let's try this again so the fall
animation is not good I think so I think
what we want to avoid is falling see
that when I fall I think I know whose
momentum okay so this is based on
nothing it's a theory what am I supposed
to do so close so close I can't make
that jump yeah Lord there's no wall
jumping all right not that I'm aware
what's kind of odd about this section is
that like I am quite genuinely stuck
like I have no idea what this game is
asking me I'm just when you're up top on
that high ramp and you jump backwards
onto the wheel
we are high enough to reach the top of
it I could try and go backwards wizard
I'll take a little hint nice [ __ ] what
why are you crying
he's yelling at me now I don't
understand he's on bag oh my goodness
don't be mad at me I'm playing a game
right now
I'll deal with you see mom can you hear
him he's yelling oh he okay I cannot
touch the ball
oh you can't touch it at all dang
so we can't run but I don't think I can
make the jump so I am gonna try being a
little I'm gonna try hiding okay so we
know to jump here
[Applause]
oh there it is Neela I didn't see
mini-game we are the greatest
he always Nina in my chain Tina hi
before I forget oh my gosh this looks
weird
what's going on Louise you're not I
think an attack on us
this person is talking to me yeah before
I forget if you guys like watching scary
games I play Silent Hill every Thursday
with hentai PhD so I'll be playing that
tomorrow night so we're currently on
it's coming so if you guys like Silent
Hill come hang out with us yeah check
out Mary's channel can't let you threat
the King safety need to leave a strong
partner to stop him from running through
oh god why do you go like I know a
teammate why they give making me give
them people no no you may not watch me
Oh
I think I have to reconsider not giving
them a teammate because he murdered me I
just to understand why I keep having to
give them yeah that's a bummer and I
don't have that many all right did I do
it
my first name thanks for joining us
um what is going on I don't know that's
wild
we have just under a half hour left in
our stream and we are still collecting
donations and raising money for black
lives matter and KOCO 19 direct relief
so thank you everyone who's donated so
far and if you've done it before and
play for all we really appreciate it
thank you so much this is honestly a
part where it's possible that I need to
go get another teammate like I need to
start going backwards in the game this
is based off of nothing I'm just I have
to clear a teammate and I don't have
it's a working theory that I can give
him so I can't give him any teammates I
can go backwards and maybe find one also
I have $48 maybe I can buy a teammate
right yeah this game has been really
tough with the money we've discussed
this before working so inexpensive
everything's so expensive
can I what I was seeing was this can I
fast travel with my job but it doesn't
looking great shows how far we've come
oh yeah
I tried the whiz I tried the wizard this
oh and I already gave away the wizard
was a I her if I've already I've already
gave the wizard to someone DCCC asked
how long will you guys be doing play for
all we are doing play for all charity
streams until July 10th so that's next
Friday so July 10th will be the last
charity stream that we do but we'll
still be covering and we might still be
covering some things after that oh my
god the charity streams will end on the
10th
would you guys have anybody else cool
coming up that you're allowed to talk
about my buddy Jack Pattillo is joining
us on Tuesday and I'm gonna put him to
the test with some movie trivia so
that'll be fun one oh you guys are
together for that yeah we did it a
couple times so uh Rob did the games
trivia and he was the postmaster on that
and then I was the quiz master for movie
trivia for the entertainment team so the
next trivia we do which will be on
Tuesday is gonna split the difference
and we're gonna have two members of the
games team two members of the
entertainment team and Jack on the panel
to answer
[Music]
oh that's so cool it'll be fun you're
good at trivia you used to do trivia all
the time at bars yeah I like being a
quiz master I've never done it before so
I had a blast making questions for movie
trivia so I'm gonna be doing that again
this week and then we'll have the trivia
on Tuesday so join for that because
it'll be fun I am not good at trivia
because I panic under pressure so it can
be something that I like I know them
very well it could be like yeah I'm
gonna be like toss press and I'll be
like I don't I'd forgot who he is like I
will panic under the pressure
I'm terrible trivia I just don't handle
I don't handle that well there is a lot
of pressure that is for sure guys
yelling at me I'm basically running
around looking for a need to get someone
on the team so that I can sell them and
move on yeah essentially what's
happening it's kind of a weird time how
do I even get out of here oh there's a
ladder down here it's a very pretty game
even though I don't know what's going on
most of the time yeah
what about you me what who oh that guy
can I have you he won't give me the
option again
[Music]
I'm just looking for a person so that I
can use them oops I died
what do you think about this game so far
it's definitely weird yeah it's it's got
a really good art style the puzzles like
some of them are really clever and
beautiful and other ones are just like
oh why yeah see yeah yeah but overall
it's it seems like a fairly Chill puzzle
game I'm looking through the schedule
for play for all coming up and we do
have super eyepatch wolf tomorrow
I love super eyepatch wolf he just did a
charity stream oh nice
on his own right I think he played he
played a game for like 24 hours Wow I
don't think I can do that I know I don't
think I could either I could try but I
don't think I can do that
but he raised like over $10,000 for he
did a really good job that's great so we
actually have two streams on Tuesday I
should mention in the morning at 10 a.m.
Pacific time we'll have cam and Seb
returning for top 5 Skyrim mods of all
time so that's really cool and then the
movie trivia will be at 1 p.m. if you
want to join us for that as again and
then on the 8th we have Elise and James
Williams from fun house and then we'll
have our K G on the 9th so those are
some of our pals that are joining us
sweetie you're gonna have a good stream
yeah
please someone join our team I know I'm
like actually stuck I'm like genuinely
stuck right now this is hard that's the
one that kills you there's like one of
the mere pass will it take you to
nowhere land [ __ ] I just whoa huge
donation just came in oh my goodness
two huge donations this came in yeah a
generous donations oh my gosh you guys
are getting stickers you got your name
on the board what's going on you're in
huge shout-outs alright we got a shot
these out Brock Denham gave $100 Rock
gone on the board yeah there you go
there's Brock's name Brock Denham thank
you so much for your generous donation
to black lives matter next we have sage
an orcid John Peter $25 to black lives
matter thank you so much this is so
awesome you were you are both getting
stickers and names on the board
thank you sir Thank You sage and then
$100 from Powell brickowski thank you so
much Powell Powell thank you so much
$100 is so generous thank you so much
for helping us to raise money for black
lives matter stickers for all three of
you I really appreciate that
we really appreciate that that's so
awesome
no steady one you didn't ask a
legitimate question so you can actually
listen to me for a second is that she
add thank you for that prime sub-prime
nice nice nice
she asked a NGO Mero subbed yay yay
thank you
yay um no I'm gonna call this [ __ ] out I
don't like this in my chat someone said
steady one said they asked a legitimate
question about why we're not like
helping out racism against Caucasians
and I'm gonna answer you I'm gonna tell
you why that these things are the way
they are we have a system we have a
systemic issue here we're not talking
about whether or not
Caucasians can't have hard times that
they can't have problems in their lives
that they can't experience things that
are negative we're talking about an off
balance issue here where people who by
the color of their skin will have a more
difficult product I'm doing very
standard things that you and I don't
have problems with Google redlining
Google the prison system we have [ __ ]
up issues that are happening in our
world then we need to educate ourselves
you need to get educated on it you need
to figure these things out don't come
into a chat and tell me that we don't
give a [ __ ] about these things I care
about your problems I care about the
issues that you face but that's not
we're talking about here black lives
matter does not mean that white lives
don't matter that's your [ __ ] problem
and you can learn about that [ __ ] on
your own time get out of here there are
plenty of links and resources to educate
yourself just check any thread on
Twitter I don't like that and I'm not
having it you want to ask a dumb
question I'm gonna give you a good
answer
it's ridiculous I and the thing is is
like you can care about both like you
can care about your problems it's not
like other people don't face issues but
black lives matter doesn't [ __ ] hurt
you that's ridiculous
mm-hmm anyway anyway that guy was an
[ __ ] anyone else have any questions
I'm [ __ ] stuck yeah this is this is a
tough one we can't even find anyone to
try minutes I'm gonna move games cuz we
have 15 minutes left and I have another
really good game I want to show you if
that's cool yeah go with that absolutely
I'm so cool with it we got 15 minutes
left in the stream still plenty of time
to raise more money for black lives
matter and kovat 19 Direct Relief so
those links are right there on the
screen for you and if you're in the
GameSpot chat they are in the
description as well so thank you to
everyone who's donated everyone who is
on the board your your awesome
we've got stickers on Mary for everyone
that donated 20 or more if you're
confused by that and joined late but
thank you guys so much for helping us
thank you guys for putting in your
effort to have like a good time in this
and like thinking about this from like a
universal issue like when we talk about
kovat or we talk about anything that
we're raising money for today we're
talking about like raising awareness
we're talking about raising funds to
make people's lives easier and we're
doing it communally because we care
gamespot does not have to do this
gamespot could just go about their daily
business reviewing video games and
putting up gameplay trailers it's what
pays the bills the fact that GameSpot
does this shows that they're trying to
use their platform to do something good
and it's worth listening and paying
attention and seeing what we can get out
of this we're doing this together
and so it's dope that you guys have like
included so many people and that you're
doing this over an extraordinary long
amount of time this also could have been
something that they've been
I don't know like you guys could have
just done this for two days this is like
a 45 day issue like the thing that you
guys have been doing right this is a
long six weeks six weeks so there's a
lot of effort in this and you guys are
awesome for doing it and I just think
like we should appreciate that and all
the effort you guys you man to it
there's been a lot of human effort to
make sure that this was successful dope
work Xie thank you for donating oh my
god you don't into 37 dollars I really
appreciate that if you donated that to
me that's awesome if you don't mind I'm
gonna donate that to the gamespot
charity after thank you and in your name
obviously
if that's the case set Xie Wow we got a
huge donation I'm gonna turn that down
but go ahead alright someone just gave
us $100 and then they said
blacklivesmatter thank you very much
yes they function like life's a matter
list as well oh we just got a couple
more donations Ares one gave us $25 so
you're going on the board
Ares can we turn down the game to audio
just a little bit yeah is it really loud
how loud is it for you because it should
only be as loud as it is for the chat
which is like negative 45 okay yeah it's
kind of loud for me hmmm second row our
very own Alessandro gave us $25 as well
so how about both getting stickers
they're good that's better thinks that
better yep just gave you a couple more
names for the board and that's three
more stickers duh dollars for direct
relief and we got $25 and $25 for black
lives matter so that's three stickers
total well thank you guys so much
okay let me just put these names on here
real quick Brock you're going on you
rule
I think we got such before
I'm almost confident I wrote sighs his
name I would never forget that so it was
how old we got a song German Aires yeah
let's get Aires yeah that's that's the
one we're next Alessandra Thank You
Alessandra nice thing to do Thank You
Alessandra the did Lerner
I know you did learn thank you dude it's
so funny when I see people who are like
definitely like hang out my chat from
time to time like nice jump in on this
for a good cause diddler thank you thank
you guys for being so cool
so obviously I'm not going to finish
this game but I do think it's worth
playing dendara is amazing it's a really
cool game it's also like a I would say
this is kind of like a Metroidvania
style game where it's about jumping and
it's really cool it's also like I'm
gonna start a new game just so you guys
can experience it yeah go for it we only
have 10 minutes left so I'm not gonna
get too far in this I think it's super
worth if you haven't heard of this game
before it's just experiencing it yeah it
also by five minutes that's fine too if
there's something if you're in the
middle of showing something girl I got
nothing to do we in a pandemic I'm gonna
sit here we can stretch this a couple
more I gotta put some stickers on my
face I forgot I oh yeah three stickers
three stickers thank you so with that in
mind we do have eleven minutes left for
donations if you want to help us raise
money we are donating to black lives
matter and Co V 19 direct relief those
links are on the screen for you if
you're in the GameSpot chat they are in
the description as well um data asked
what system I'm playing this on I'm just
playing this on my computer this is on
Steam this game is so cool it's like
stunningly beautiful as well it's also
relaxing
in my opinion but it gets the reason I
didn't play it is because it gets really
hard um but it starts off easy and like
relaxing but if you guys are looking for
a challenging game you can get it so I'm
showing you what I'm doing here you pick
where you want to jump to and then you
hit a to jump so this game is about like
pointing where you want to go oh and
then L to shoot I forgot that I could
shoot
that's his game in a nutshell nice
yeah the art is really tremendous in
this game I played this on my stream
once and I fell in love with it and a
part of me would be down for like
playing it again it just gets really
really hard and there was a part of me
that was like I don't know if I'm like
ready to play a really difficult game on
this your team today I wouldn't be able
to take breaks if you wanted to like
talk about a charity and stuff like that
so you never know right like what the
best game is to play on charity right
that's very true it has been a challenge
to come up with so many different games
to play you guys have probably been
playing all sorts of games all sorts of
things yeah we've had a mixture of stuff
we had apex minecraft dungeons warzone
we've done a couple trivia things there
was one tabletop like murder mystery
with Giant Bomb that was cool oh really
who was on the table murder mystery
the murderer in history I think it was
Ben Ben Abby and Vinny joined Tam oh
yeah companies that really Ben yeah it
was Ben and Ben and Ben was there and
Ben was there too that's okay yeah Abby
did a a charity one Friday yeah we
played Monopoly and it was so funny
because I forgot how bad Monopoly is and
you cannot change in the place it takes
so long sometimes it just takes forever
to get through enough or ever
um this is Dom Dora right
this is don Dora this game is really
cool it's very simple and and then it
like kind of expands over time but as
you can see it's the same element that
we were doing before which is mm-hmm I
can jump to certain surfaces and only
for like a so much time and I have one
ability to shoot people oops I got hurt
get out of here I can't do this fast
enough there it is so you'll see I can
only jump to certain surfaces I can't
jump to like any surface so in this
situation this is a puzzle where it's
like you're gonna come out of here but
you're not going to be able to go in
there so I have to leave your gaze and
yeah just like a Metroidvania all
eventually I'll learn a new skill that
allows me to come back
oh gosh darn it I'm almost running out
of Hearts now
I wonder how I'm gonna get more hearts I
forget how to do that
this game also has a Zen soundtrack it
has a really beautiful yeah I like it
art style and it's simple like you know
you don't think too much when you're
playing it you're basically like gotta
go fast gotta go fast gotta go fast you
understand that concept like my man
sonic over here that's right did you
watch the Sonic the Hedgehog movie no I
haven't seen it I want to I'm down it's
it's so great it's so fun I heard they
made a great job with it which is like
not something you think you'd think
about it it's just delightful it's it's
a lot of fun I recommend it I appreciate
that they were able to do that I'm
actually probably much like you I mean I
I grew up yeah I'm on Sonic like it's it
means something to me whether or not
Sonic is cool or not right and like
mm-hmm I played through those original
games my Sonic 2 I played to death I
played that game over and over on my
second genesis for years yeah I had a
Genesis 2 and played a lot of Sonic okay
so there's spikes here now which is just
one now it's getting to way for me to
die so to be really careful here
okay so what you're seeing is like I'm
impressed yeah I can only go to so many
places look decide to be really careful
with like okay I think I'm oh I ran into
it so I'll return to the flag which
isn't the worst thing in the world
because I already it's actually faster
if I did that I broke the game there's a
lot of really unique spaces done Dara
can you hear me
are you still full of so many questions
you've always been so inquisitive
assault herbs and flows through the
fabric of oblivion just as it does these
very woods
I understand your journey just began
from the crib of creation but please
seek me dandera
while we still have time
this is kind of like a home base where I
can upgrade my character so you'll see
over time I can upgrade salts from what
I'm doing in the world and I use that
salt to upgrade my character so I can
increase my life we just got $20 from
Strike Eagle 78 Strike Eagle that's
going on the board and that's getting a
sticker thank you strike you go full
this board is getting if I can yeah I'm
you love to see it you really do look
I'd love to see it you'll love to see it
Strike Eagle 78 thank you for $20
towards direct relief strike II will set
great stream for great causes thank you
thank you so much and I will check on
our blacklivesmatter donations as well
thank you yes we did get a couple more
william garcia $50 well william that's
definitely on the board that's gone on
the board that's getting the sticker
burning and matthew lee lie Matthew 25
dollars towards black lives matter thank
you so much Matthew thank you guys
yeah you guys are great thank you so
much we have a couple minutes left in
the stream if you still want to donate
and we have plenty of play for all
streams come in this weekend next week
so you have more chances to hang out
with us donate help us raise money for a
great cause
but yeah thank you to everyone who's
been doing today we've been doing pretty
well this stream thank you Mary dude I
really am grateful that you guys did
this and that you invited me so that we
could talk about these like really
important issues and raise some money
for a good cause and hang out with
really wonderful people I've been super
blessed that not only have I had like a
really fun career where I got to like
work at a do a place like GameSpot and
twitch but now when I'm streaming on
Twitch I'm basically create like found a
bunch of wonderful people that
love hanging out and we have a wonderful
community and I think they're also very
supportive and that's really cool
yes that is super cool and there's also
other weird carriage we love we're
towards the end of our stream do you
want to play a few more minutes or do
you want to close this up oh man what do
you want to do we could definitely to
you yeah we just basically started this
is dandera
it's so amazing you guys should a
hundred percent play this game it's
really really good and we love it this
is the end we're basically here this is
what you guys have done we're covered in
sticky yeah let's take a look at that
board this is everyone who donated at
least $10 thank you so much you guys
Rock look at all of this look at all
these great people and they helped us
out today and put stickers on Mary's
face the stickers are all represented by
people who donated $20 or more so thank
you guys for making a dreams come true
for helping us out during this dream we
raised about eight hundred and twenty
five yeah you are a scream that's not
bad for two hours thank you so much
that's pretty impressive I'm there I've
done a couple of these streams now and
definitely one of the highest ones that
I've been on oh that's why sighs today
is like that is I changed it into a J or
i sorry change it into a heart but then
it got weird now it's got a hurt by no
regrets no regrets at all I'm gonna
check one last time before we go just in
case I missed anybody's donations thank
you so much we are still collecting
these donations through all of play for
all the screams are gonna be going
charity streams are going to July 10th
so just keep that in mind
Oh Matt Hawking gave a $10 donation
thank you again for this stream for all
the good work you're doing I love Mary's
community thank you
so much thank you you're all great so
those are all the donations from this
stream but yeah just keep them coming in
and come back for more
charity streams Mary where can they find
you do you want to plug your channel one
more time sure so you guys can probably
see it under was like where dandera was
um first of all I'll definitely play
down to alright so good and check out
the other game that we played today
bright bird that play that was a really
fun game too and you guys can find me on
my twitch channel it's called merry Kish
which is my name you can also find me on
Twitter and Instagram and YouTube under
that name because I just post stuff
there as well we have a lot of fun we'd
play a lot of indie games and horror
games and you are so welcome and my only
role is to remember the human and be a
good one so just like be kind to others
and you are welcome so please please
come on over and hang out with me and oh
and I'm playing a Silent Hill tomorrow
night so if you like Silent Hill nice
that's tomorrow great stuff that's a
good message be good to one another be
excellent to each other and remember to
take some time first at self-care as
well because you are important too and
so on play for all tomorrow we have
super eyepatch wolf at 12 p.m. Pacific
time so that definitely should be a good
stream so comeback for that thank you so
much Mary you're welcome oh wow major
thank you for subbing dude thank you
we're still getting subs and stuff
happening over here I love it I love it
here um cool well I think this was a
victory so I'm gonna play our victory
video to end Schaeffler it definitely a
victory definitely a victory and before
we end it David Dobbins $25 thank you
David yeah David that's on the board
then yeah that's on the board oh I'll
give you his name David Dobbins $25
thank you so much
thanks dude thank you so much cool on
the board
well chastity thank you for inviting me
and for doing this awesome charity
initiative and having me play a couple
silly games with you it was a pleasure
hanging out with you and doing this
thank you so much Mary
[Laughter]
oh no she'll be just raided the stream
is ending with thank you for coming
through these awesome people who donated
to play for all Thank You Jimmy I really
appreciate the raid thank you I'm gonna
send your people somewhere really
wonderful I will continue to raid so
apologies I really appreciate that you
did that especially because we're doing
a charity stream so thank you to be
thank you everybody put something wizard
will you put Shu B's name in um will you
put dammit
will you put Chu B's Dame and the thing
but thank you guys for hanging out and
I'm gonna put some victory videos in
there and we'll figure it out alright
thank you guys for joining us have a
great day take care of yourselves be
excellent to each other cool cool cool
bye
check it out
we did it nice
did you see that I won did you check at
that I got done working hard baby all
the time and if you want to get paid you
better step in line cuz we won got it
done we achieved things in that video
game
hey y'all I'm the greatest you wanna
follow for all the latest win on these
games straight up all the time but when
a log of baby now you're on my mind
[Music]
we got it done
I'm the greatest your greatest
yeah
[Music]
you
are you still here
[Music]
I'll see you next
you
[Music]
you